ages chivalry Renaissance Festival
returns for its 28th year over at Sunset
Park so I had to immerse myself into the
Renaissance Era and see what they have
planned for the weekend check it out
hear ye hear ye the age of chivalry
Renaissance Festival returns to Sunset
Park one of my favorite events here in
Las Vegas and we are here with Christy
the time at Traveler tale Storyteller
Christy thank you so much for hanging
out with us tell us a little bit about
what you do out here I tell stories from
throughout history throughout time I'm a
time traveler of course so I'll tell
creation myths from the nors from the
Irish and my most favorite story is The
Sword in the Stone taking you from a
meteorite to Excalibur and you said
you've been out here for over 20 years
my 21st year yeah and it's so much fun
the fair is already underway happening
at starting at 10 A.M every day
throughout the weekend let's walk over
here a little bit because not only can
guests come and listen to stories from
you but they can also walk around get
some clothing items food or what else
can they experience when they come to
the Renaissance there's jousting and
there's the pirate parrot which is a fun
fun show there's belly dancing and the
queen in her Court there's turkey legs
and giant glasses beer there's something
for everyone yes I haven't seen butter
beer back there shopping over here I
actually got some of my gear you're
looking at this booth right here at the
CH Hutchinson they have everything from
Scottish hats to the swords to a little
bit of everything I had so much fun
walking through there and this is just
one of the many things that you can
experience out here at the fair and
everyone is just in costume listening to
good music what's your favorite thing
about the Renaissance Fair my favorite
thing about the Renaissance Fair is just
that it's open to everyone it's got
everything from Romans to the queen
inner court and everything in between
it's huge you can go all the way around
the lake so it's fun with kids in
strollers and even dogs I think yeah
perfect for the whole family be sure to
get your tickets online it makes it a
lot easier you can save a few bucks too
parking is free but yes we're really
encouraging everyone to get their
tickets early it's happening through
Sunday be sure to come check out the age
of chivalry Renaissance Fair I'm here
with Cole and Eric you guys ready let's
do it here ye hear ye absolutely
foreign